les forces russes mettent les forces
iraniennes en grande difficulté un ici
dans la région hier les forces
ukrainiennes ont dû abandonner certaines
de leurs positions dans la ville de lima
n'est d'ailleurs les troupes russes les
soldats russes ont commencé à entrer
dans cette ville et c'est une très
mauvaise nouvelle pour les ukrainiens
parce que cela signifie et bien qu'une
fois que les russes or on est bien placé
leur artillerie à ce niveau là au niveau
de la ville de liman est bien la
capitale régionale 1 cramatte or ce que
non loin d'ici sera à portée de canon et
c'est là où se concentre le commandement
ukrainiens nous avons pu aller sur
certaines lignes de front à ces derniers
jours et tous les commandants le disent
ils font face à deux problèmes majeurs
d'abord le manque d'hommes parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de blessés il y a beaucoup de
morts et bien les unités ont des
difficultés à trouver des troupes pour
remplacer ces blessés ces soldats hors
de combat et puis l'autre problème c'est
cette artillerie massive à laquelle les
soldats font pas ça il faut mesurer ce
que veut dire tenir une tranchée sous le
feu des canons rechain dans certains
endroits où nous sommes allés c'est
simple vous vous marchez à travers ses
chants sur ses lignes de front tenue par
les soldats ukrainien et le sol est
constellée d'impacts d'obus donc ce sont
ce là les deux problèmes auxquels font
face les ukrainiens aujourd'hui ceci
étant et il faut le dire on n'insiste
pas dans la région à une retraite a
massive des ukrainiens on a pu voir des
lignes de front qui sont solidement
tenue on voit des soldats qu'ils sont
fatigués c'est vrai qu'ils sont
concentrés mais qui ne sont pas du tout
démoralisée et les commandants ce que
vous disent les commandants c'est qu'ils
ont encore des options tactiques ils
opèrent des retraites ils essaient de
contre-attaquer dans certains endroits
l'un des officiers que nous avons pu
voir hier nous le disait la semaine à
venir sera décisif